Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more people
in the audience, we're doing it via Discord,
a David Pakman dot com slash discord is the
place to find the mechanism for phone calls.
Let's go to Oh, let's try Maria from Maria
from Columbus, says that she's ready. Maria,
you're on the air. Hey, can you hear me, I
can hear you now. Maria, what was happening
before?
Speaker 6: I have no idea. I have no open
on my laptop. OK, now I'm on my phone, so
got it. Don't know what that's about. Sorry.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm glad you were able to
make it on.
Speaker 6: Yeah, me too. I'm really sorry
about your Twitch ban. It's a pretty both,
in my opinion.
Speaker 1: Yes, please don't swear. Remember,
this goes on the radio. So every time you
swear, we've got to bleep that part. Please
make a note. We're going to bleep Maria. Yes.
The Twitch ban is a disappointment, for sure.
Speaker 6: Yeah. So I appreciate you covering
the trial, though it's it's hard to talk with
anyone else about it. Everyone else seems
very annoyed about the whole thing. I am as
well. I'm very frustrated. The judge is insane.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't. I mean, I'm trying
to sort of be as as least hyperbolic as possible
about the judge. But in particular in particular,
when he. Completely fell for this entire objection
from the defense that zooming in a picture
is in some way equivalent to algorithmically
creating 3-D images from a still from a still
image, and the judge was sort of like, I don't
know what they're doing. Yeah. It was. It
was just humiliating. It's just like, what?
Just like, he's completely not understanding
what's going on.
Speaker 6: Yep, I feel like you should have
some sort of education on on what he's judging
about technology. What is there?
Speaker 1: Yes, yes. And the burden of proof
were just the mere bogus objection from Kyle.
Rittenhouse's attorney led the judge to say
to the prosecution, You're going to have to
like, bring in a witness and prove that this
stuff hasn't been altered. So wait a second.
There's been no serious allegation that it
has. It's just some vague idea that Rittenhouse's
attorney had. It was all bizarre.
Speaker 6: Completely. Yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: What do you think will be the verdict,
though?
Speaker 6: Realistically? Yeah, I think he's
going to get away without any issue, which
I wish was not the case. But, you know, I
don't think from how it's going. I don't I
don't think he's going to get any sort of
punishment.
Speaker 1: Here's my real issue. I've said
I think self-defense is plausible in the homicide
charges, particularly with Anthony Huber.
I think it's totally plausible. The sick thing
is that this kid is already a product of the
disgusting gun culture of the United States,
and his acquittal is going to fire up the
militia and gun people even more. He'll be
seen as a hero. He'll be invited to sign headshots
and speak at gun conventions and whatnot when
this is actually a tragedy, what took place?
That's that's really my concern here.
Speaker 6: I agree completely. Yeah, yeah.
So from the standpoint of third vaccinations,
have you gotten yours yet?
Speaker 1: I'm going very, very soon. I've
got an appointment actually in the next day
or so, and I I will report my symptoms. But
yes, I'm getting my third dose very soon.
Speaker 6: That's great. I received my on
Friday, and I am happy to report that I am
now magnetic, I wasn't after the second dose,
but now I am. You mean
Speaker 1: literally magnetic or you just
now have a magnetic personality,
Speaker 6: just quite literally magnetic.
Oh wow. There's a lot of metal on me right
now. That's crazy. My laptop isn't working,
actually.
Speaker 1: I think that explains why you were.
We weren't able to hear you earlier, actually.
Yeah. All right, Maria. And by the way, that's
a joke, Maria. We're all kidding. We're all
Speaker 6: kidding around. I am kidding. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Thank you, Maria. Appreciate the
call. Thank you. All right. There's Maria
from Columbus, Ohio. Pretty damn close to
a perfect phone call, I would say.